suck blood
this week on thug most dumb panties
Niagara fallen with madame bovary by
gustave flaubert
mama's boy Charles Bovary so damn boring
he put my mess to sleep just thinking
about him probably eventually hop off
his mama's titties struggle his way
through med school and finally find a
job riding as a scrub level doctor one
day mama slang some old easy name
Heloise his way and be like drop your
drawers son cuz this is your new wife
yeah she got a stick up her ass
but word on the street is she inherited
some fat stacks so Charlie and Heloise
get hitched and move to the boonies one
night Charlie beat drops in at a farmer
man's crib the fix is busted ass leg
when Bob boom the farmer's daughter emma
is fine Charlie fina so hard for that
ass he started making it up just so we
can stop buying peep game and Emma sex
Alicia's booting whoa back home ha
Louise get worried that some sheisty
lawyer jacked off her Benjamins and bam
girl drops dead now Charlie all cashed
out but hey at least a sample again hey
so Charlie hoist up his nuts
holler at Emma and they jumped that
broom together but the married life
ain't what Emma respect him girl been
thinking them cuffs with me and getting
high off passionate romance 24/7 like
she read in the books but since chilling
with Charles not as romantic as going to
the DMV girl got an itch that Charlie
just can't scratch basically she a freak
one night Emma get a little taste of
that ball of lifestyle doing a party and
a phat crib Emma peep the scene and her
panties immediately hit the flow now
this is living after that girl rolling
around mad depressed now that she know
how other people shining while she's
slumming it up with Charlie's weak ass
Charles decided he gotta get his woman
to a different spot so we packed this
stuff and slang over to another hood one
evening
Emma meet Leon a smooth-talking law
student who all about that romance just
like she is later it will pop out a baby
girl named Barrett but the only thing
running through this girl's dome is
Elia except Emma don't want society
looking at her like she's some kind of
rank oh so she put her feelings a lot
but it ain't easy not being sleazy she's
a man putting out and Leon got
watermelon nuts by now who like [ __ ]
this and pieces out the parish next
thing you know another creased up layer
name would off drops by the crib takes
one look at Emma say yeah that girl
needs to get [ __ ] weird all start
macking on Emma
and it ain't long today getting buck
wild on the rig it was all up on his
dudes nuts wanting to run away with him
and he'll get in so deep she start
borrowing is for some shady cat so she
can buy swanky things to impress with
off but soon rode off like I didn't hit
it and it's about time to quit it so
when she say boy let's run away together
you can hit this very night he sent her
a letter saying ah my girl I'm good
thanks though
Emma get so toe up she almost throws
herself out the damn window and gets
sick as a dog by the time she recover
Charles buried under the bill she been
stacking so do borrowed cash from that
saying shady cat and now they balls deep
in debt later Charles decides to take
Emma to the Opera when I guess who be
chilling mother [ __ ] Leon who riding
so clean next thing you know Leon and
Emma creeping up to a hotel on the DL
when they spent all that time straight
freaking on each other doing it dirty
thing is girl keeps throwing cash around
and make the affair that much funky girl
can't keep her last clothes or her
pockets full eventually they both get
bored diddling each other's private
parts and call it quits but she is so
deep with the Sharks the first come down
to her ass and try to seize all of dish
with bangs get desperate she fires
Rudolph and offer him everything if
he'll give her the mints and I mean
everything
and first he's stoked to see you but
when he recognized all she wanted that
chatter he say no blood I already hit
that so she throw back some arsenic
Charles try to save her for a few hours
but she did since Charles ain't got
nothing but love for his girl he sends
her around like a G one day he finds a
bunch of love letters from rode off an
Lea
oh she was banging - dudes while I'm
working my ass into the ground oh hell
no surely after he dies in his garden
and little Burt remember her get shipped
off the ground at a cotton mill all day
every day
damn one of the dankest things about
this text right here is the redonkulous
attention to detail word on the street
is that Flo bear will spend months just
trying to write one damn sentence so
that every word serves a purpose just
check this mad flow right here but as
their outward familiarity grew she began
to be inwardly detached to hold herself
more aloof from him
Charles conversation was as flat as a
street pavement on which everybody's
ideas trudged past whereas man surely
should know about everything excel in a
multitude of activities introduce you to
passion and all its force to life in all
its grace initiate you into all
mysteries but this one had nothing to
teach knew nothing wanted nothing he
thought she was happy and she hated him
for that placid and mobility that stole
the serenity of his for that very
happiness which she herself brought him
but by the end neither one of them got
any kind of happiness that's for sure I
mean how did things get so [ __ ] who
gonna ride the beef of this mess
should we blame Emma for letting her
while outside get in the way of being a
good wife and a mama why should we blame
Charles when that pudding in work up in
the bedroom what about Leon and Rudolph
or maybe it ain't the players we should
be hating on maybe it's the game and if
my bears jam the game is reality see
Madame Bovary got mad cred and academics
streets for reppin some skal
very realism basically this book is full
of 100% real talk
gustaf and pushing fancy words on a
reader to make life sound prettier than
it is so no matter how high these
characters getting off their passions
fly better describe their lives like it
ain't no thing for example when Charlie
be booking for miles just leaking peep
game and Emmas ghetto booty the tags
read like this he went into the kitchen
and at first failed to notice Emma the
shutters were closed flies were crawling
over the dirty glasses on the table
buzzing as they drowned themselves in
the dregs of the cider
Emma sat between the window and the
hearth sullen she had nothing round her
neck and little drops of perspiration
stood on her bare shoulders only a
brother packing a rage and romance boner
what bust ass that far just a peep game
and a honey but this pass is written
like the least romantic thing you ever
heard fly Barrett's killer flow reppin a
bigger theme up in this piece that
beneath whatever romantic idea our
characters got going on in their domes
there's reality and a lot of times
reality don't always dive with your
expectations
Charles thinking he got a legit marriage
but on a real this woman getting wild
with multiple dudes behind his back I'm
always thinking that she's gonna live
that romance life like in the novels but
on the real she just getting played but
it ain't all depressing baby our boy fly
bear got jokes too rustling and irony
all up in his Vista flexes dark sense of
humor for one doing Ellis funeral
Charles make damn show she getting
buried in her wedding dress to wrap her
purity purity Emma
aa-are up at the Agricultural Fair rode
off spitting game at Emma while another
dude is announcing the winner of a
manure contest basically rode all
foolish but him a blinded by says she's
such a damn freak
nice one good stuff I see you man that's
a good one and maybe that's the point do
our dreams guide us about a ball so bad
that we blind to the way they trip us up
do they mess with our head so much that
we can't even see the decent life we got
in front of us or maybe it's even
more depressing maybe flower bear
preaching that no matter how hard we
hustle to live our dream life reality
just gonna spit all over it should ever
have just satisfied her fantasies and
settled for that wife life always
chasing the life you want worth it
no matter the consequences mmm hey
thanks for kicking it with your boy man
thanks yo thanks for kicking it with me
today looking for your next great book
why not driving to another literary
classic by heading to audible.com slash
thug notes and downloading Pride and
Prejudice by Jane Austen narrated by
Rosamund Pike from gone girl I check out
the thug notes book it's got detailed
breakdowns on 16 literary classics
including Pride and Prejudice and it's
narrated by me your main man Sparky
sweets audiobooks are adult way to enjoy
great stories while making the time fly
whether you're hustling at the gym are
stuck in a long-ass commute Oliver makes
it easy to enjoy the huge collection of
audiobooks original audio shows comedy
and more no matter where you are just go
to audible.com slash thug notes to start
a free 30-day trial when you sign up you
can pick Pride and Prejudice those notes
or any book you want download it for
free and it's yours to keep forever man
put more about audible in the star your
30-day free trial with a free audio book
go to audible.com slash thug notes to
sign up huge thanks to audible for
sponsoring this video and we've got more
great thug notes on the way so click
here to check out our channel page and
be sure to subscribe while you're there
thanks for the support y'all and thanks
for watching
peace
you